all right let's see what is on the minds
of folks in the audience don't worry I'm
not taking phone calls right now I know
that that would be the absolute worst
nightmare for many in the audience we're
not it's Thursday we're not taking phone
calls phone calls will be tomorrow you
don't have to turn off the show I am
talking about the david pakman show
subreddit at david pakman.com slash our
EDD IT a few posts that came to my
attention a lot of people ask me about
this Eric Weinstein recently tweeted
about the left I think the left has
reached a hard fork those that want to
explore extreme wolken a-- so pijn
borders anti whiteness apologizing to
homophobic misogynistic receive world's
without men reparations for slavery
cancel culture etc need to branch off
and good luck you'll need it listen here
my view about this is there i i wouldn't
call the left having i don't believe the
left has reached a hard fork i think
that on the highway of the left it's not
even an off-ramp it's like one of those
driveways that usually says for
authorized vehicles only that people
aren't really supposed to turn off of
it's not actually an exit it's not the
highway splitting and there are some
people on the Left who are going in that
direction I maintain that that group is
smaller than many make it out to be and
disproportionately loud particularly on
the internet but again in the same way
that those of us in internet culture
don't understand where are all these
Biden supporters but then when you go
into the real world you see there's lots
of people that you just don't really
hear from in the online political milieu
who support Joe Biden that's a reality
it's not an endorsement he's not my guy
I'm just telling you Joe Biden does have
more support than you would glean from
being online this wing of the left this
sliver of the left is I call it has less
support than you might believe if you
spend a lot of time on Twitter and on
reddit so I I don't agree with Eric
Weinstein that it's a hard fork but I've
pointed out that there are people on the
Left who who share the priorities that
he's listing there another post about my
hair and we're actually going to talk
about this a little bit later
I knew David's hair was reminding me of
someone please reassess head symmetry
and hair goals in 2020 god bless
for the S post and there's a picture of
Gumby yeah there have been some
technical issues we've been experiencing
with my hair over the last few days and
I'm actually going to talk about it on
tomorrow's program so I don't want a
short-circuit that conversation now and
lastly there was a shirtless picture of
me that went up on my Instagram a couple
of years ago I think it was me jumping
into a pool in northwestern Spain or in
Spain not in northwestern Spain and
there are more and more calls for that a
post that says it's been almost two
years since shirtless Packman pics have
surfaced David should post more
shirtless pics on Instagram for the
people yeah it's not happening anytime
soon but sometimes incidentally there
will be a picture very very zoomed out
where I am
maybe shirtless join the discussion
I suggest participating in the one about
the hard fork on the left rather than
about my hair or shirtless pictures at
david pakman.com slash our IDI di t